[Music]
oh man
[Music]
i'm the cook in my family my son is less
than a year old my husband doesn't even
know where the stove is so i'm really
excited to just like sit back and let
someone else cook
pretty
nice i mean this looks so fancy yeah
it's very nice presentation
that's got to be there megan find the
urchin
this is my first time
hi kennedy and rosie hi so we did
pistachio salmon and honey glazed
carrots with garlic mashed potatoes what
was the hardest thing to cook kennedy it
was just the time pressure was just this
was probably the hardest round
hi even jen you want to tell us about
your dish we made a creamy sea urchin
risotto with a quail egg hollandaise
balsamic reduction with caviar amazing
eva how do you feel about the round we
just feel really confident in our dish
good for you thank you guys
annika nanu
we made prawn scampi with homemade pasta
and crunchy gremolata breadcrumbs have
you made ingredient hair before yes but
i learned it's very hard to make it for
like so many people so i think we took a
little bit of a risk thank you thank you
anakin and news dish is very
sophisticated everything on this plate
that made it very flavorful prawns are
very easy to get wrong they can become
very rubbery and this was perfectly done
and the pasta is well prepared i love
that little heat of spice to it prawns
are the most important part so that is
very
little victorian
what do we think about kennedy and
rosie's salmon didn't shy away
from the high end ingredient they
actually highlight the pistachio and
that beautiful honey the salmon's
perfectly cut i do find the pistachio
encrusted things to be a little 1980s
which is interesting because kennedy was
not alive at that point no she was not
between one to ten what would you say we
did
eight even jen's beautiful risotto the
rice is overcooked but it's definitely
something you would get in that michelin
star restaurant execution is not perfect
but i love these flavors i would put
this on a tasty menu anytime wow i want
to hear what your thoughts are since
this is your first time with urchin this
was yummy yeah the aftertaste was like
oh i'm swimming in the sea i think the
flavors were really great that was
really delicious
detail how old were you when you started
to cook i was about 12 peeling some
carrots for extra money to go surfing
when i was that age i was only eating
things that were orange or beige it was
just the thing i had
no judging no judging over here
we have five minutes mexico is perfect
i don't know what's wrong with this but
it's not good my secret sauce the base
is always soy sauce and sriracha
i think it just needs more ketchup but i
added a little bit more scratches i want
like a flavor punch in your mouth and
then we have to put the lemon zest on
top yeah just don't want it to melt a
minute you put the cilantro on that's
shaking you're gonna come in with a
sauce yeah
i feel good
ketchup in the sauce
yeah
oh wow we're killing it
karen and moy do you want to tell us
about your dish i have a kobe beef sushi
bite so it's a fried rice cake with
fried kimchi and my secret sauce how did
you make the rice we made sushi rice cut
it and then we fried it in the pan feel
good about this ram yeah
ish
thank you thank you
are we confident
our luxury ingredient was hormone
debiota so the main part is jamon
wrapped sea bass and then we had caviar
on top some arugula and we had a hemona
robesco sauce
thank you
hi brooke and carol we made a chilled
lemon mousse with candied pistachios and
a pistachio biscotti you're the only one
who made dessert i wanted to stand out
from everyone else
really smart thank you so much enjoy it
so what do we think of brook and carol's
lemon tart i find biscotti really hard
to make i overcook mine i love that
there's a chewiness to this one i was
like this better be the best cookie of
all times and it was it was so good
i thought jack and bobby came unwrapped
sea bass so it cooked perfectly the uh
man serrano the way they wrapped it
around the fish brought a really nice
salt flavor yeah to be that young and to
understand that like so focused it's
really really genius
here in a moist dish i thought the rice
was so crunchy but not in a good way
that sriracha doesn't belong on the kobe
beef there because everything you taste
is that hot sauce just trust the kobe
beef
going to give you all the reasons that
you want we got stress of each other but
it's okay
still looks good okay i got some truffle
pieces to put on the top i'm worried our
dish is too simple that we're not
highlighting the truffle enough we need
to hurry yes we do
[Music]
you